ich habe für euch den spanischen
Highspeed Zug Ave in der ersten Klasse
getestet das Land spanien hat seit 2012
das größte höchstgeschwindigkeitsnetz
weltweit sogar vor China und ich bin von
der Grenzstadt 4GS bis nach Barcelona
gefahren wegen den Bahn Terroranschlägen
vom März 2004 Madrid muss man unbedingt
die höchstgeschwindigkeitszüge zu
gelangen durch den Security Check und
der öffnet auch erst ungefähr 5 Minuten
bevor der Zug losfährt da habe ich mich
in die erste Klasse gesetzt da war
eigentlich fast niemanden Getränke
umsonst ich habe noch ein Brötchen
getestet alles in allem was wirklich
sehr lecker wir waren pünktlich 99,5%
pünktlich und ja ich hatte eine sehr
entspannte Reiseanbieter ich kann euch
diese Züge auf jeden Fall empfehlen